oh hello there we got a jolly frost
flavor today who can take your heart out
chop it up for you [ __ ] you in his
freezer so his contract can renew the
ice cream man
Oh God guys don't ever make me sing
again on the plus side we have a new
season of Sabrina and I know I know it's
technically part three not season three
but I just know some Melvin in the
comments is gonna be correcting me that
being said we have a ton of stuff to
explain this season was absolutely
bonkers so if you haven't subscribed yet
and smash that like button you might as
well be sacrificed to the green man in
this video we'll be going over the
entire ending unanswered questions and
what could be in store for season four
so if you want to skip right ahead to
the seasons for stuff I've left a link
in the description below but if you do
you'll be missing out on change
shirtless Nick shower shirtless Nick
other change shirtless Nick now let's
get into it the beginning of the last
episode is super important mainly
because it depicts what happened to
Sabrina after being backstabbed by hot
Prince of Hell Caliban if you look
closely here you can see Ambrose's hands
and that this book is being read by him
in the kinkle mines where we'll later
find he's found refuge with Sabrina
Lucifer and Lilith all confined and
stoned in the ninth ring of Hell Caliban
began his quest to take over earth to
make it the tenth ring of Hell what
Caliban didn't expect were the pagans
who have harnessed the power of the
Green Man and they were actually able to
push a Mac and if things couldn't get
any worse for our clay mate hell was
attacked by the Celestials heavenly
creatures and completely emptied so
basically Caliban was like the worst
ruler ever and the world has gone to
hell wait no not how you know what I
mean
decades pass until stone Sabrina is
saved by
yes I'm gonna call this one future
Sabrina who has harnessed the power of
time and task current Sabrina was saving
the world and stopping this time loop
for good but how is she to do this only
by collecting the unholy regalia three
pieces of immense magical energy can she
have enough power to travel back in time
and stop the pagans but before she can
grab the regalia she's stopped by its
Guardians
Vlad the Impaler a real-life ruler of
Romania in the 1400s who Brahm Stoker
famously turned into a vampire in his
1897 book Dracula which by the way if
you haven't seen my video on Dracula
check it out he watches over Judas's 30
pieces of silver which is the amount of
silver Judas received for betraying
Jesus there's even a legend hinted at in
the show that Judas was the first
vampire and Vlad even says Judas was his
father
there's also King Herod a real king who
ordered the slaughter of fourteen
thousand male children under the age of
two when it was believed that one of
them would grow up to be the true king
the true king referring to Christ and
finally Pontius Pilate spall the Roman
who ordered Jesus's death and famously
washed his hands of any wrongdoing
leaving the blame to the Jewish
establishment who wanted him dead since
his claim of being the Son of God didn't
sit well with them instead of stopping
Sabrina the three guardians join her
their purpose was to protect these items
for this moment
for someone to come along and restore
balance to the worlds of heaven hell and
earth
Sabrina teleports home and it isn't a
pretty sight decades have passed and
were treated with a parade of skeletons
Agatha and prudence Zelda and the voodoo
priestess Marie and even Hilda and Salem
bonus points if you cut Sabrina picking
up that jar that holds badda bat the
sleep demon from episode 5 which will
later be used by Sabrina to trap Faustus
Blackwood but Sabrina strip down morbid
memory lane is cut short by these
creatures
Sabrina also visits Baxter High which
has been overrun with snakes this is a
reference to one of the pagans the
Gorgon or the snake charmer who Barbie's
dad even stranger is the writing
the chalkboard that reads please Lord
deliver us from Carcosa which refers to
an 1895 short story the king in yellow
which mentions a city named Carcosa a
mysterious ancient and cursed place just
like Greendale at the carnival Sabrina
sees the bodies of her friends and the
feeding of the Green Man with fresh
human blood after reuniting with Ambrose
who by the way still looks his normal
self even though decades have passed
since witches and warlocks age
differently than mortals Sabrina's told
that humans have been sent off to flesh
factories where their blood is harvested
for the green man one of the oldest if
not all discard which the pagans brought
back to life Ambrose has holed himself
up in the kinkle mines where he's done
nothing but research having also spent
several decades gone completely mad they
figure out that the only way to stop
this future from happening is if Sabrina
goes back in time and stops the pagans
from coming to power but in order to
harness the power of this egg which
holds the ability to manipulate time
unimaginable magic will be needed
thankfully sabrina has the unholy
regalia which Ambrose forges into a
Morningstar weapon ironic since morning
star is Sabrina's hellish last name the
only problem is that in order to perform
the ritual they'll need a sacred stone
circle to perform it and the only one
that's still around is at the Academy
where Faustus Blackwood holds sway to
make matters worse Blackwood was given
the mark of cain by Lilith essentially
making him uncle Abel the Mark of Cain
originates from the Bible where it said
God gave Cain this mark which promised
him divine protection from premature
death to circumvent this sabrina makes a
deal with batty bat sabrina will set her
free if she agrees to never bother the
Spellman's again so bad about is
unleashed on Faustus who puts him in a
dream this allows Sabrina to create a
vortex using the Morningstar and travel
back in time moments before [ __ ] hits
the fan
she teleports everyone to safety so a
new plan can be hatched at the same time
Zelda is awoken from her unconscious
state after being shot by Miss Ward well
at the end of episode six
Faustus posing as a priest implanted in
Ward wells mind that the Spellman's were
responsible for the death of her true
love atom now she wants revenge what a
great Christian well unconscious Zelda
experiences
visions of the past present and future
which all make references to the moon
that's why when she comes back to
consciousness she proclaimed she knows
how to get their powers back to stop the
pagans the answer the moon God Hecate II
dating back to ancient Greece
Hecate II was the goddess of magic
witchcraft the night moon ghosts and
necromancy fitting since necromancy will
be needed to save Hilda Hilda was killed
by Zelda and put in the cane pit to be
resurrected but it never happened
likely because they powers the witches
once held a result of worshipping
Lucifer have since been depleted now
that they worship equity they are imbued
with new power enough to fight the
pagans speaking of the pagans they've
arranged free admission caramel apples
and rides at their carnival all an
elaborate plan to implant seeds via the
apples so that when the green man is
finally restored he can pollinate the
townspeople Sabrina and the gang decided
to put a sleeping lullaby on the
residence while Robin gives the pagans
the last piece of their puzzle a virgin
in the form of Mary ward well with
everything in place
the pagans begin their ritual only to be
tricked miss ward well isn't Ward well
at all it's a plague made known as Pesta
with the ability to rot organic material
The Witches reveal themselves to the
pagans like some sort of Sabrina version
of endgame
[Music]
with the pagans on the run Roz and
Harvey go after the Gorgons sicker axe
who in mythology is actually caliban's
mother but it's never really mentioned
in the show she's a Gorgon like Medusa
with the ability to turn anyone who
looks at her to stone this is why Harvey
goes in holding a mirror kind of a
loophole to not be affected by her
powers but when his mirror gets smashed
he's saved by Ross who really should
have gone in in the first place since
her cunning ability would have allowed
her to see without opening her eyes in
another act of revenge Hilda is savage
as completely contorting Circe more than
a Cirque du Soleil performer and Hilda
is rightfully angry it was Circe who put
a spell on her that made her gradually
transform into a spider which resulted
in the death of her true love doctor
Cerberus this is what happens when you
get in the way of a woman who was
supposed to audition for Sweeney Todd
but as we'll find out later dr. C is
alive and well having been wrapped up in
a cocoon but not eaten and finally we
have the god of the pan-flute in ancient
Greek mythology pan was the god of the
wild
his name is where we actually get the
word panic from he actually doesn't have
much time to play some sweet tunes since
he's stabbed by prudence back at home we
have a really important scene with these
Spellman's which outline Sabrina's
journey and arc not just through this
season but through all three Sabrina
says being the queen of hell is her
destiny something in previous seasons
she said she would never do Zelda also
thanks Sabrina for putting the coven and
her family first when previously she was
chastised by Zelda for choosing the
opposite can you believe this Hilda your
niece chose a throne in hell over her
coven and her family but there's still
something Sabrina must do
Sabrina promised the future Sabrina that
she'd come back and end this time loop
but Sabrina has a plan that will both
end the time loop and solve her biggest
dilemma how can she be both queen of
Hell and a regular teenager to
understand this we need to track our
Sabrina's first we have what I like to
call future Sabrina who is still trapped
in stone and was the one who helped
present Sabrina changed the course of
history since President Sabrina was
successful and changed history this
means there's no more future Sabrina
because that part of the future now
never happened president Sabrina then
informs knew Sabrina not
to fall for Caliban strick thereby
stopping him from coming into power and
continuing the time loop the to
Sabrina's in secret come to an agreement
that present sabrina will live in
Greendale after all she spent decades in
stone and saw the skeletons of all her
loved ones while new sabrina will live
her life as queen of hell with hal
finally stabilized with its new queen
the realms of heaven hell and earth are
finally stable but for how long
back in Greendale Robin says he's going
to stay and it's heavily hinted that
Harvey finally loses his vCard prudence
and Ambrose seemingly in their
relationship when prudence upset over
the death of her sister Dorcas blames
Ambrose since he was the one to stop her
from killing Blackwood when they had the
chance in Scotland if Ambrose had never
stopped her none of this would have ever
happened and Dorcas would still be alive
Zelda proclaims that the Church of night
is now the order of Hecate E and mumbo
Marie who has offered a place to teach
at the academy tells her she senses
something is in the air and that they
must prepare for war before they kiss of
course with Sabrina as Queen the season
begins to wrap up leaving us with many
possibilities as to what will happen in
season 4 and the ending of the season
gives us a few clues first we have Nick
and prudence both of whom have left
their partners finally reuniting I think
it's safe to assume that these two will
end up being a couple especially
considering that Sabrina lit that
candles to stop her feelings towards
both Nick and Harvey but if there's
anything we know about spells and
Sabrina land it's that almost anything
can be reversed I also think the
introduction of Marie is a love interest
for Zelda means we'll be getting more
voodoo magic next season in the fight
against Faustus and the eldritch terror
I'll get into Faustus in a bit the to
Sabrina's leave us with crazy
possibilities as to what will happen but
it's Ambrose who gives us a clue that
things can't go on this way not to
mention the bad omen of the cuckoo clock
falling Ambrose tells Sabrina that she
has created a time paradox the
ramifications of which are horrifying
and as Sabrina even said to her family
the universe has a way of correcting
itself if anyone is to discover the to
Sabrina's plans it's likely Lilith
notices everything
well if could be a problem yeah and
let's not forget that little
is supposedly pregnant with Lucifer's
child a male heir she got this by doing
the dirty with Faustus who had Lucifer
within him when he was his flesh Acheron
it will be interesting if a male heir
will change Lucifer's mind as to who
will share the throne with him finally
we have the cliffhanger ending where
Faustus along with Agatha Judith and
Judas unleashes the egg creature into
the world calling upon the eldritch
terror to make him a vessel the eldritch
terrors are said to predate even the old
gods with the ability to change space
and time this sense that time travel or
perhaps even different versions of
reality will come into play more next
season but what exactly is this egg
obtained by Faustus by what seems to be
the Loch Ness monster though unconfirmed
in the credits is some sort of alien
fetus which can bend time the term
eldritch was popularized by author HP
Lovecraft for a creature that disregards
the laws of the universe and in many
horror stories it's referred to as an
alien who lives outside the dawn of time
let's also not forget that Faustus was
imbued with the mark of cain making him
invincible and doubly threatening to
both hell and earth knowing this show
however nothing is ever invincible
everything always has a weakness along
with Faustus being a villain there's
also the potential that Queen of Hell
Sabrina could be swayed to the dark side
influenced by both Lilith and Lucifer
this means that we could see Greendale
Sabrina fighting an evil version of
ourselves of course there isn't a
release date yet for part 4 but stay
tuned to my channel by liking and
subscribing for all the latest Sabrina
updates I got all sorts of cool videos
on the horizon so stay tuned let me know
what you thought of the season below in
the comments and until next time
remember